and this is it the biggest ship in
Ukraine's new as of sea fleet which
Moscow says threatens its interests in
the region
Donbass passed through the Kerch straits
in late September without incident
adding weight to a fleet that previously
consisted largely of these small patrol
boats one of the ship's officers tells
us that since losing Crimea Ukraine's as
of Sea coastline has been left all but
defenseless levana just saw both
witnessed at the moment Russia has many
times more ships in this region than
Ukraine whether that's Coast Guard boats
FSB Security Service vessels or Russia's
Black Sea Fleet
you just can't compare it the ships
captured by Russia would you to join
Ukraine's naval forces in Mariupol many
here know the men taken prisoner
personally but sailors were not allowed
to speak to us on camera
most of them began their service in
Crimea where Ukraine's Navy was once
based when Russia annexed the peninsula
the sailors faced a choice stay put and
swear allegiance to Russia or abandoned
their homes and leave to continue
serving Ukraine something these men
chose to do unlike many of their former
comrades Mariupol is the city the
sailors are called on to defend home to
nearly half a million people marry Paul
stands in the shadow of the front line
its future depends on the ability of
these huge steel plants to supply the
rest of the world keeping tens of
thousands of people in work but that's
now under threat
Ukraine accuses Russia of trying to
suffocate the region economically using
trumped-up Security checks to bring
civilian shipping to a standstill
these checks can take weeks and have
already seen many international shipping
companies decide to stay clear of the
Azov sea altogether
one of the port's engineers takes us
along the unusually quiet key side trade
was already dropping significantly
before last weekend's incident since
then Ukrainian officials insist
not a single civilian ship has been able
to pass in or out of the Azov sea from
Ukrainian ports even though the scars
the last conflict are still all too
visible here for now it seems like
weariness is the prevailing mood in
Mariupol so everything's all right
people have got used to this kind of
thing already for us this doesn't feel
unusual so nothing's really changed for
us so far we haven't seen any big
changes I don't see any changes for me
personally all I've noticed is that we
got more police patrols than I'd like
what they say just a week ago few people
outside this part of Europe had ever
heard of the Sea of Azov let alone
Mariupol
now the fate of some 20 Ukrainian
sailors and the port behind me has been
catapulted to the top of the
international and gender enough to see
g20 meetings canceled and to put fresh
sanctions against Russia back on the
table but strange as it may sound the
mood here in Mariupol is karma the
Ukraine's capital Kiev for the past four
years checkpoints and the sound of
shelling had become part of people's
everyday lives here with the frontline
just 20 kilometers down the road many
people here in mareep all are seemingly
unwilling and unable to believe that a
new escalation could be just around the
corner back on the donbass they're
hoisting the ceremonial flags preparing
for the ship's birthday with martial law
in place it may be the only celebration
these sailors will have for some time to
come